welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B and bad batch just wrapped up
season two leaving us with way more
questions than answers not exactly the
hopeful ending we all wished for unless
you enjoy death and despair yikes I
guess it's just a bad boy breaking down
bad batch feeling bad feelings about all
the bad things that happened in that
batch that has been baked things are
looking dicey for clone Force 99 but
perhaps not all hope is lost before we
get to the two-part finale we have to
talk about episode 14 Tipping Point and
boy was it we are now on a collision
course between the bad batch and the
Empire things are looking down for the
Clone you see a few disobedient clones
being put aboard a prison transport by
Stormtroopers at an Imperial base on
balmora this is another location that
previously existed in Legends timeline
in both books and the high Republic
video game it's now Canon it's Canon
baby we brought it back there is still a
clone Commando working with the Troopers
so it seems as though those clones are
still on board with the Empire's plans
why could that be I wonder Captain Rex
and Echo are able to rescue the captured
clones by docking out of the ship the
officer on board uses his Electro
suicide pill to off himself same way the
Clone assassin did earlier in the season
Echo is able to extract some of the
plants from the ship but a star
destroyer shows up and they have to flee
we get an awesome base filled teaser of
The Imperial March before Captain
rexinko speed away with a partial upload
of the plans echo's going to need
someone with genius level skill and
Technology a tech clone if you will but
could that be anyway Crosshair remains a
prisoner on Tantus Under The Evil Eye of
Dr Hemlock shout out Jimmy Simpson crowd
doing some great evil Voice work this
season Crosshair immediately sniffs out
hemlock's plan to capture Omega and
refuses to cooperate this allows for the
return of my least favorite robot the
interrogation torture Droid you remember
that fun little guy from New Hope right
don't like him Rex and Co head to a base
on the outskirts of Coruscant to meet up
with Tucci the senator who is fighting
to make sure clones get paid their
veteran benefits upon retirement the
John Stewart of senators making sure
those vets get taken care of we head
back to Tantus where Crosshair plays
possum after being interrogated then
steals a gun and dispatches the Troopers
he does set his gun to stun when he
takes out the doctor who showed Mercy on
him by shutting off the torture Droid
Crosshair he makes it to a control room
and is able to send out a distress
message where he's trapped in there as
gas begins to flow in the toxin is a
special home brew Hemlock made himself
and he goes full dread pirate Roberts by
also making himself immune to it as you
wish one moment I really loved in this
episode was a great callback to text
racing abilities showcased in the
speeder races in episode 4 faster
episode 14 shows us Tech is teaching
Omega how to fly and asks her to execute
a difficult maneuver she excitedly calls
detection do the tech team the tech turn
you know you got skills when the name
and moves after you it seems the bad
batch have decided to stay on Pabu which
means that everyone there will soon be
dead that's just the way things work
guys when the good guys say they're
hanging out the townspeople get killed
we get some nice background details of
Twilights and rodians helping to rebuild
the town and one person who is really
loving life on Pabu is rekka he's
fishing making friends presumably eating
a lot things are good for him the only
thing that could possibly be better is a
reunion that's right that goes back baby
which is good because Hemlock is gearing
to meet up with Governor Tarkin who we
know his grandma from A New Hope in
Rogue one Hemlock is suggesting
tarkinson all the Clones to him so he
can experiment on them big time Nazi
scientist Vibes and I gotta say I think
I hate this guy the bad batch receives
crosshairs transmission and though they
aren't sure if it's a trap or not as he
trapped him in season one they decide to
try to rescue you him this is very
convenient for Dr Hemlock however
Hemlock seems to be overlooking the fact
that the only clone Crosshair might even
care a little about is Omega so here we
go things are percolating for the final
stretch speaking of stretch our merch
Partners at nerd riot.shop have some
great new Mandalorian inspired items and
they're new the way collection including
the foundling shirt and this shirt
called The Bounty Hunter with designs
inspired by the best guy steal of the
Mandalore now if you purchase one of
these shirts you can opt to unlock a
shout out on the show we'll say anything
Eric and I will uh tell your girlfriend
you want to propose you could tell your
husband you're pregnant whatever you
need we will shout it out visit
nerdright.shop to grab one of these
great designs and don't take it off
until the finale next month I don't care
how much you stink I want to smell it
the final two episodes The Summit and
plan 99 bring an exciting conclusion to
season two of the bad batch Echo and
Tech have spent the evening trying to
gather Intel on the advanced Sciences
program headed by Dr Hemlock they've got
to find out where he is based although
us viewers know it's Mount Tantus on the
planet Weyland Tech refers to Dr Hemlock
as a ghost with little to no information
known about him how ever one of the
Clones working with Echo and Rex has
given Echo the Intel that Hemlock is set
to attend a summit at tarkin's Compound
on iriatu the team hatches a plan to go
to the summit and capture Hemlock and
rescue Crosshair fee stops Tech and
gives him a flirty line so we were just
going to leave without saying goodbye
that is correct Tech completely misses
it a further nod to his possible
neurodivergence it also his lack of
reading people's emotions really paying
that off sometimes when you love a show
or a movie it's not enough to have seen
it you need some merch to commemorate
the occasion and nerd riots got you
covered baby if the finale of The Last
of Us left you hungry for more pick up a
lunch of us tea available in cream or
black featuring the logo of Todd's
Steakhouse from episode 8 of the series
don't eat there though just don't do
that unless you're a cannibal if you're
stoked for the upcoming John Wick movie
nerd Riot has a whole lot of John Wick
shirts to make you feel like you've got
a seat at the high table there's the
Baba Yaga team my personal favorite a
gun Chucks tea a tea for the high table
itself for claiming I have served I will
be of service get them all now you can
wear them opening night and then you can
wear them again the next weekend and you
see John Wick chapter four for a second
time and of course you're obsessing over
the Mandalorian right now there's a
whole line of Mando merch in the way
collection with teas beanies hats even
stuff for the kids there's a lot of new
fun exciting merch coming up and I can't
give away too much but let's just say
it's Barbie's World we're just living in
it to get your hands on the merch you
need head to nerd riot.shop today join
the riot over at nerdriot.shop
The Marauder heads to ariatu as does Dr
Hemlock Star Destroyer Target's compound
is manned mostly by Stormtroopers from
the new conscripted Army further showing
that the high-ranking imperial officers
are more weary of the Clones and trying
to move away from them Hemlock is
escorted to the meeting room where
Tarkin is waiting with other Imperial
bigwigs including or synchronic Ben
Mendelson's character from Rogue one The
Marauder finds a safe place to land and
is able to bypass the Imperial Cruisers
because Echo has a clearance code given
to him from one of his contacts on the
inside it's clear now that Rex and Echo
have built a sizable network of clones
both inside and outside the Empire that
allow them to access almost any point in
the Galaxy without being hassled they
can go undetected if they hitch a ride
on the cable rail system that leads
right into the compound Tech is able to
disrupt the system and the bad Batcher
Hemlock is explaining how things are
going with his cloning research he says
his work is of great importance to the
emperor now we know all these Disney
Plus shows are trying to fill the gaps
and provide an answer to the somehow
Palpatine returned quote poor Poe
Dameron had to say in the rise of
Skywalker reactions to the table are
mixed to Hemlock man some of the men
think that just using the Clones is Lab
Rats is in the little in poor taste the
meeting turns with Tarkin asked critic
about project Stardust and if your mind
saber just ignited it's because that is
the name of the project that created the
death stars all connected baby
Omega showing more of her hold her
own-ness that she's obtained this season
places a tracking beacon on hemlock's
Lambda shuttle she is almost busted by a
mouse droid but wrecker manages to
squish it with his foot stupid Mouse
droids all they do is tattle on people
or at least try to before they get a big
size 15 squish them down Hunter and Tech
discover thermal explosives and also
discover they're not alone as saw
Guerrera is also there attempting to
blow up the compound it's a rogue one
reunion baby the batch has to hustle out
of there and hops back on the rail train
and are mid Escape when the explosion
rocks everything and takes out the power
which leads us to our finale the finale
begins with the bad batch train car and
a standoff with another car filled with
Stormtroopers Tech goes to restore power
to the car and is rewarded with a squad
of v-wings leaving him hanging by his
tether in the most heartbreaking moment
of the Season tax sacrifices himself
allowing the rest of the bad batch to
fly down the track and crash into a
nearby Field rip Tech I think so we
didn't see a body later in the episode
Hemlock hands goggles over to Hunter God
I don't want to be dead but it does not
look good the surviving bad batch are
able to flee to ord mantel to get help
from azi 3 the medical Droid from last
season Hunter has to break the
devastating news to Omega the tech is
gone she's inconsolable obviously an
ornamental the gang gets the medical
attention they need but at a price as
Sid finally sells them out this moment
has been building all season I've said
in almost every episode Sid is about to
sell these fools out so I guess I'm
Vindicated but at what cost it doesn't
feel good Hemlock arrives and is able to
capture Hunter and wrecker but Omega
tries to save them and is instead
captured herself Hunter and record meet
up with Echo they escaped The Marauder
but they cannot track Hemlock ship the
final scene on Tantus Omega is reunited
with Namaste and also discovers that
Crosshair is still alive the female
doctor working with Hemlock questions
Omega on wise trust Noah say but not her
she then reveals to Omega that she is
her sister so what does it all mean is
this connected to this season of the
Mandalorian Elliot Kane also a sister so
many questions well we are gonna have to
just wait and see that's all for now
follow me at Tommy back told follow new
rockstars at our sister stationed at the
game time don't forget to like the video
and subscribe to the channel and until
next season
[Music]
foreign